[Music]
marsh guess what
chicken butt
who told you i told you
who the [ __ ] told you
uh today is national telejoke day you
know what that means
news anchors are going to be telling
some jokes for us
wake up news taking a live look at some
gorgeous sunshine out there for you on
this tuesday again i feel weird talking
what if it's all
like inside jokes like you know it was a
real cut that's susan in accounting what
a [ __ ] about the weather would have
been
openly [ __ ] talking their co-workers
what i thought this was a roast just
keep it simple it's a
lovely sunny day here on uh santa monica
and what is the difference between a
mexican and a park bench
find out on the rumble exclusive show
next friday bessie you have to remember
to finish the joke then um
and uh folks it's a beautiful day out
there and it is national joke day and uh
you know they uh had me asking
what do you call ten thousand black
people at the bottom of the ocean
find out after news and traffic weather
like what is happening
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
hey what's hey what's up hey my name is
royce
what's what's the puerto rican national
anthem
one half of the us's national anthem
[Laughter]
hey rice here again what's the
difference between puerto rico and costa
rica costa rica is an actual country
sorry let me press play i thought the
puerto rican national anthem was a fat
joe song
i don't want to be a player no more
stand up for the buddy
hey do me a favor take off your fitted
yankees cap for the puerto rican
national anthem
you're like i don't take this thing off
and no nobody dog for nobody
um
it's going to be nice today that's all
we got to say by the way they're they're
national they're national like you know
that they're a state animal or whatever
it's just a picture of eddie kingston
and an extra is he
that's their state bird that's the same
word
your dog your dog ain't no bird bee
why do you have an eddie kingston on bro
i needed so basically i needed a puerto
rican for the on the ready and i go i
might as well get eddie kingston if i'm
going to get a puerto rican i like that
this is like like mid-2000s czw eddie
kingston yeah no i know but because i
need him to look as puerto rican as
possible prime kingston prime cam this
is this is this is great a kingston
there you go merc he's going to join you
for a little bit that's a wacky kingston
beer and massaged it every day oh god
okay let's go get a egg sandwich after
this
well today is august 16th and it's also
national tele-joke day get ready for
this we invited some of our wake up
family here to tell oh god oh god this
is going to be so bad oh i could already
feel how bad this is going to be good
family here uh hey karen what do you
call a black astronaut oh god no
what do you call cheese that doesn't
belong to you what it's nacho cheese
dude you just you tune you get up in the
morning you like brushing your teeth you
tune into a show called wake up and
they're like we're gonna tell some jokes
you know like i'm going back to sleep
i'm going to sleep now jokes all right
so let's start with our ch
oh no oh my god oh my god they set up an
entire oh my god
by the way that means that the improv is
paying for this one hundred percent emma
head off
i thought they were each gonna just tell
a joke are they gonna do like a tight
five well i mean oh [ __ ] they're doing a
tight one but yeah this thing on
yeah they should we should stick a fork
up your ass
plugged in i love it completely all
right why do elephants paint their
toenails different colors
because they're
listen i don't know i'm not a lizard
i don't know i'm not a lizzo fan
[Laughter]
that should be that should be the punch
lines like hey why do elephants paint
the toes different colors i don't know
ask lizzo
you're fired al what are you doing all
right
okay let's see let's see his punchline
oh i can hide in bags of m ms
wow that joke [ __ ] sucked tom
they should do this but then also in the
jokes bomb fight they're fired exactly
have you ever seen an elephant in a bag
of m m's
it's working
unlike you're going to be if you keep
telling these jokes tom
this is soul crush
i wouldn't do this this is why i
couldn't make it in a modern life i love
this bird no no i'm not doing this i
love this so much okay here we go
we're gonna you couldn't even get a
better cricket sound effect we're going
to try to get things back on track here
all right uh what happens when you cross
a very angry goat with a very angry cow
again i'm not a lizzo fan
they're not are these all gonna be
animal jokes i think they are yeah yeah
they're not using the mic on the stand i
know they're using sorry i think my
autism is tickling me either i can't
help i know they're [ __ ] lapel mic
still
damn it
you get two animals in a bad mood
yeah there we go i like the sound
effects on these too
nikki's a little slower over to the mic
yes it's the shoes
why are elevator jokes so funny
because sometimes ray rice punches his
wife in one of them
they're only funny when they involve
domestic violence [ __ ] seriously
why are elevator jokes so funny
because so many people were trapped at
him in 9 11.
nice man that's what they were saying
oh my god they said that too
this is
maybe what if she does that exact joke
how funny would that be if she does the
exact 9 11 joke
oh sorry
they go up and down they work on many
levels
that [ __ ] joke makes you want to keep
yeah but let me tell you you doing this
it's you're definitely not going to be
on willy wonka's elevator breaking any
glass ceilings so
[Laughter]
honestly the hardest part about this is
getting to and from the hardest part
about this is the erection i have
the hardest part about this is [ __ ]
listening to it
[Laughter]
right maybe we should stay closer
so why does snoop dogg use an umbrella
for drizzle you [ __ ] for drizzle
for drizzle
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
he's so messy
like i'm just like looking at this
feeling sad for
[Laughter]
pesky you ruined the joke
as soon as it went over so well the
first time i stepped on her throat okay
calm down
seeing as the elephant joke went over so
well first time what did tarzan say when
he saw the elephants coming over the
hill
why is lizzo in africa
it's just all lit
see now that would have been funny it
would have been funny if they all just
had these animal jokes hey listen you
know liz was wearing a hat going like
don't do the voice
[Laughter]
here come the elephants what guitars
what did why when what did tarzan say
when he looked in the mirror holy [ __ ]
i'm white
[Music]
that's racist
sans say when he saw the elephants
coming over the hill wearing sunglasses
why is little wearing sunglasses
i can't i'm sorry i'm done
i should be a news anchor nothing he
didn't recognize him
oh my god
where are you getting it
what would you guess would be a pirate's
favorite letter
are you serious
are you serious
oh i know i know i know i know i know i
know
er
yes
hard r
oh [ __ ]
you would think but his first love was
the c
when are we gonna get rid of the c word
i'll leave when i'm good and ready
[Applause]
more pesky there's one more
so what if this woman walks up and does
10 minutes of like vagina amy schumer to
your jokes just grunty [ __ ] [ __ ] i
feel like you guys all have good like a
good stage run too like you got to come
up like that i have a presence
why do you [ __ ] one black guy because i
couldn't find a second one
what
ma'am
what
i know it's milwaukee no one's watching
but still
i didn't know that they had mud sharks
in milwaukee there's not very many
shallows for them to swim in are you
kidding me i knew some of my uncle used
to play for the milwaukee mud shot yeah
it's true they were sure
yeah i i remember that they played at
ebt stadium i've been there
[Laughter]
um
i only stadium when you get five [ __ ]
concessions with food stamps yeah
exactly
it's all cove all the concessions are
cold food so you can use the ebt card
i want to have i want to have a [ __ ]
baseball jersey made now
[Laughter]
they're going to be playing the
cleveland spear truckers hold on
red one red one has one why is tiger
woods named tiger his mom was ty
and his dad was black
these are good jokes oh [ __ ]
okay
all right
this is not really a joke
yeah i know i i know i know i know why
it's not really a joke because a woman
is telling it
okay here we go no this is probably also
written by jeffrey ross he writes
everything
grabs the stool why people [ __ ] like
this
black people [ __ ] like she starts
okay
so so this really isn't a joke and she
does the entire 25 minutes of gringo
bobby
you are you are wow
finish off strong finish off strong
just laughed and he never laughs okay
let's wrap this up
you know what i love banter news banter
is always i despise it news banter
is always the best well can you tell
these people all genuinely like each
other
they look forward to seeing each other i
don't i don't think i don't think they
look even hulk is still disappointed
guys